so today is the day of donald trump's
second
impeachment trial vote
there's a lot of [ __ ] to unpack from
today and really honestly from this week
but the one thing that people keep
talking about
is the democrats
decided to vote for witnesses and then
after winning the vote for witnesses
they did not call any witnesses
there's a lot of stuff to unpack about
this particular vote
the house managers wanted witnesses and
the one witness they wanted was
the house republican that was willing to
make a statement
under oath about kevin mccarthy's uh
a recount of his conversation with
donald trump
on the day of the insurrection
which shows that donald trump had intent
and his intent was to incite an
insurrection
and not only to incite an insurrection
but to maintain the insurrection
to not do anything the [ __ ] about the
insurrection in the moment
there's plenty of stuff that donald
trump could have done
when he realized that not only the
members of congress but his vice
president was under duress
from the people that he sent there to
put him under duress that's why donald
trump didn't do anything
that's why he didn't [ __ ] make any
moves or he didn't try to protect the
vice president or
members of congress for that matter
[Music]
because he intended to send them and he
intended to intimidate those people
with his mob with his supporters
that was the intent and that is why the
member of congress the
republican member of congress that
congresswoman
wanted to testify under oath and the
house managers
wanted her to testify under oath now a
lot of people
have been placing blame on democrats
because it seems like they caved
but they didn't really cave here
because what what would have been the
story if if this member of congress
who voted to impeach donald trump he was
already
already an eminent enemy of q anon maga
trumpsters
coming to the senate to testify
under oath and as soon as she's under
oath that well that's not true
that's not true you're just an you're
just an anti-trumper
you're a never trumper of course that
would have been the excuse
and the defense would have stopped off
her her her
statements as if they were untrue
so it would have gone no further and it
would have prolonged the process by
possibly a week or two
which meant that republicans wanted to
hold coronavirus
hostage because to move on with further
business the republicans could hold
other business hostage if they hadn't
adjourned the trial
so democrats decided to submit her
statement that she already wrote
last night as part of evidence
which would have been nothing really
different than the the statement she
would have made
under oath in the senate
so here we sit and we try to blame
democrats
well [ __ ] me democrats voted not only to
make this
make sure this is constitutional but
every [ __ ] one of them
every one of them voted to convict
donald trump plus
seven republicans seven
now that's not enough to get a
conviction because in our great
constitution it lays out two-thirds of
the vote
of the majority because we worship a
filibuster
and if there's not one goddamn
conclusion we need to come to
here it's that the filibuster needs to
[ __ ] go
now [ __ ] the filibuster and anything
that looks like the filibuster [ __ ] them
we do not need a minority party
especially a minority point of view
the republicans in the senate all don't
even represent
40 percent of the country here
don't even represent 40 of the
population
and we're giving them credence in the
minority
as if as if they should have some super
power
over the majority and that's why this
country is in such shambles
it's because we're letting the minority
run this [ __ ] country
and it's ridiculous sit down and shut
the [ __ ]
up enough is enough of this 71 million
people
70 million people 70 some million people
vote donald trump even released a
statement after the acquittal vote
talking about 70 some million of his
people
that he got the most votes the sitting
president's ever gotten
in history of ever ever ever well good
for you you
[ __ ] idiot it was seven
million [ __ ] votes short
because 81 million people voted against
donald trump and that's the thing we
need to take away here
is that even though two-thirds of the
vote wouldn't vote to convict what is
obviously obviously guilt
in a political trial and an impeachment
hearing on the united states senate
floor
but in a general presidential election
we don't need two thirds vote we don't
need it
as long as we go vote against
fascism not just trump not just q and
not not just
trumpism fascism in general
and we can see it clearly now it's more
clear than day
of who's the fascist it's very clear
that 43 senators are either
full on fascist borderline fascist
closet fascist
are you straight up nazis
you pick you [ __ ] pick
and speaking of republican senators
the [ __ ] garbage out of mitch
mcconnell's mouth
[Music]
and his little [ __ ] diatribe after
the vote
all of a sudden this [ __ ]
becomes a democrat
becomes a never trumper all of a sudden
as soon as before the ink even [ __ ]
dries on the
on the new york times front page of
donald trump's acquitted
this guy's already a radical liberal
socialist
never trumper a traitor
on the floor of the senate talking about
how
well if donald trump if donald trump he
can be convicted in a criminal court you
[ __ ] damn right he will you [ __ ]
around and find out hide and watch he's
gonna be
if anyone believes that donald trump is
not gonna be tied up in some criminal
court somewhere
you are a [ __ ] bonehead
he's never been able to stop committing
crimes and he won't stop now
him and his [ __ ] little family
but then mitch mcconnell goes on to say
the reason why he voted to acquit
is because this trial was
unconstitutional
you dumb [ __ ] the united states
senate gets to decide
via the constitution of
rather a [ __ ] trial on a former
official
that was in peace while he was in office
the president specifically is
constitutional
they took that vote the constitution
lays it out very clearly
very [ __ ] clearly
the senate decides the proceedings
of an impeachment trial it's their
[ __ ] responsibility
and they voted with the help of
six [ __ ] republicans
that it is constitutional so bam baby
your little [ __ ] argument about not
being constitutional is done
mitch mcconnell better beg for
forgiveness here
big either that or sit down and shut the
[ __ ] up
we got work to do
the country is ready to move the [ __ ]
forward to to
to do something about coronavirus and
get this goddamn [ __ ] under control
make sure the vaccine is [ __ ]
distributed
get people who need help help
[Music]
and let's [ __ ] appoint merrick
garland as attorney general
and get on with this [ __ ]
and get to the criminal trials of these
criminal [ __ ]
these criminal magaquinon [ __ ] already
let's get a real attorney general on the
job merrick garland you are going to be
the
busiest [ __ ] in this country
because [ __ ] donald trump and anyone who
looks like donald trump
[ __ ] him